with tens of millions of Americans out
of work there is growing concern that
many could be evicted from their
apartments or their homes in our
financial fallout series we've been
reporting on the economic impact of the
coronavirus the federal cares Act
temporarily shields some people living
in federally subsidized housing and some
states have put a short-term hold on all
evictions but our consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Warner found that
protections are hodgepodge and a
hodgepodge normally not a good thing and
you've also found that some rules aren't
even being followed good morning to you
good morning and that's right Gail we
found some renters facing eviction who
shouldn't be because they live in rental
properties that appear to be covered by
that federal cares act moratorium of
course that's on the subsidized
federally subsidized housing most
runners don't even have that federal
protection and many of them don't have
any protection in their states either
it's nice and bright and sunny before
the pandemic took her job
Rhonda Englander says she worked as a
contract medical assistant visiting
patients homes they stopped sending you
assignments in mid-march what does that
meant for you financially no income no
income at all none no income she says
meant she couldn't pay the April rent on
her two-bedroom apartment in Boise Idaho
she says she asked the complex manager
to forgive her rent or help her in other
ways they were not willing to work with
me nor were they willing to waive any
administrative fees or late fees how do
you feel about that incredibly angry
knowing that I'm one among so many that
are experiencing this some states
including Massachusetts and Delaware
offer temporary protections from
eviction and the federal cares Act put a
120-day moratorium on evictions for
those living in federally subsidized
rental properties but some advocates are
seeing problems the calls have just
doubled in the last couple weeks
Richard Kling runs an Oklahoma City
University program that gives free legal
help to people facing eviction they
don't know what to do they they're
getting threatened with eviction they've
lost their job and so they're just
frustrated and scared they're scared
take
Yona Stallings who lives in the Oklahoma
City metro area she lost her job in a
middle school due to kovat and fell
behind on her rent then her landlord
gave her an eviction notice yet Kling
found her apartment complex is covered
by the federal eviction moratorium
something he pointed out to the property
managers in this letter warning them
their action could be a violation on
Tuesday we spoke to one of the complexes
owners who said this was a screw-up by a
local manager that neither he nor the
management company were aware of the
eviction warning given to Stallings
until yesterday and he said we
immediately stopped that but Kling says
it's one of several cases he's seen at
various properties in the area I'm
seeing a small piece of the action how
many people are getting threatened with
eviction and intimidated and scared and
are they gonna move out when they could
stay there for four months
I want to prevent that well in many
parts of the country evictions have been
put on temporary hold they've been held
off Bob pinna gir with the National
Apartment Association insists most
people won't face eviction even if
they've been put on notice because many
courts are closed at this point nothing
can happen until the courts reopen that
could be anywhere from weeks to months
but the renters don't know that and they
are panicked well I think if we if you
if you watch the news and the television
you know this is things that are being
talked about right now by and large the
industry is working with residents and
setting up payment plans still many
people will all months of back rent
experts worry a housing crisis is
looming this is the worst economic
crisis the United States has seen in
generations and Matthew Desmond a
Princeton University professor who runs
the eviction lab project says if nothing
else changes and evictions continue as
normal and this public health crisis
will turn into a full-blown
crosses now the federal moratorium is
set to expire on July 25th housing
advocates are pushing for a national
moratorium for all renters not just
federally subsidized housing renters
they also want billions of dollars from
the government to help these renters out
by the way Rhonda Englander you know in
Idaho she did get her April rent covered
through a local charity she said she's
not sure what she's going to do about
her
875 dollar rent payment for May an
attorney for her complex told us that if
they forgave her rent they'd have to
forgive everybodies but he noted that
they have chosen not to evict anyone for
the month of April Tony forgiving
everybody's may be the only solution
we've got an economic crisis the last
thing we need right now is that to
become a homelessness crisis as well if
addictions skyrocket Anna thank you very
much